Yo, c'est Cyrus, et bienvenue dans cette vidéo un petit peu spéciale,
on est dans un cadre assez estival,
je suis avec un selfie-stick, voilà, comme quoi ça arrive à tout le monde!
Euh ... Je voulais vous dire quelques trucs,
ben déjà ça fait longtemps qu'on ne s'est pas vu, et ça me soûle!
Donc voilà, je voulais faire cette vidéo pour vous reparler un petit peu,
recréer du lien, parce que ...
ben vous comptez beaucoup, quoi !
Vous comptez beaucoup et, même s'il y a Facebook, Twitter, etc.,
c'est pas la même chose sur YouTube parce que ...
je viens de YouTube à la base,
et vous êtes plus nombreux là et ...
les commentaires, enfin, le lien qu'on a là,
c'est pas pareil sur les autres plateformes.
À chaque fois c'est des liens différents, en fait.
Mais bref, celui de YouTube, ça fait longtemps, et donc ça me manquait.
Et il y a différentes raisons à ça, du fait qu'il n'y ait pas eu beaucoup de vidéos,
je ne vais pas rentrer dans le détail là maintenant.
Mais, en gros, concordance des différents trucs,
les formats qui n'allaient pas,
tu vois, par exemple Cyrusly ...
tu vois le truc sur les Panama Papers, eh ben, il faut le sortir vite,
et donc du coup, ça devient une priorité, par rapport à d'autres trucs
et donc du coup, ça prend place sur Le Coup de Phil', et cetera,
et genre, j'ai fait un Cyrusly sur Nuit Debout, par exemple,
que je n'ai jamais sorti, genre ça m'a pris grave du temps.
Alors heureusement, sur Cyrusly je ne suis pas seul,
j'ai des coauteurs qui m'aident, des potes ...
mais même, c'est assez complexe.
Donc voilà, c'est des trucs que j'essaie de ...
j'essaie de faire en sorte que la rentrée ne soit pas comme ça,
et de pouvoir vous sortir beaucoup plus de vidéos à la rentrée,
et c'est pour ça aussi que je fais une sorte de petite pause.
Je pars. Voilà, j'ai décidé de partir, à la fin de la semaine,
je pars pendant trois semaines,
à plus de sept-mille kilomètres d'ici,
je pars dans une sorte de retraite spirituelle.
Je vais essayer de vous en faire une vidéo très sympa,
je vais donner mon maximum, et je vais faire un making-of en live
de cette vidéo-là sur Snapchat.
Voilà. Donc en fait, sur Snapchat,
je vais filmer quand je serai là-bas donc ...
je vais faire tel plan, j'ai telle idée,
et en plus je vais vous partager des trucs un petit peu culturels, un petit peu vlog
que je ne ferai pas, que je ne mettrai peut-être pas dans la vidéo,
parce que je n'ai pas envie de faire un vlog de voyage ...
je ne pense pas ... enfin bref.
Donc voilà. Je préfère vous prévenir en amont, en fait,
c'est pour ça que je fais cette vidéo en amont, avant de partir,
parce que j'ai pas mal de trucs à faire avant de partir, il faut que je termine ...
il faut que que je boucle pas mal de choses,
mais ça me tenait à cœur de vous dire que, sur Snapchat,
je ferai une sorte de making-of en live de cette vidéo-là à l'étranger.
Et donc ça peut être hyper cool, donc venez ! Venez !
Et la dernière chose que je voulais vous, c'est qu'il y a quelques mois,
j''ai fait un projet ... j'ai commencé un projet avec Google,
en gros, j'adore l'art, je suis aussi un gros fan de nouvelles technologies,
et Google m'a appelé, ils m'ont dit "Est-ce que tu as des trucs à dire sur l'art et les nouvelles technologies ?".
J'ai fait "Grave ! J'ai plein de trucs à dire sur l'art et les nouvelles technologies !".
Et du coup, on a fait une vidéo qui est sur leur chaîne, la chaîne "Google Art et Culture"
C'est une vidéo en anglais,
donc c'était un petit peu un challenge pour moi,
mais je suis assez content du résultat,
et je l'ai partagé à pas mal d'entre vous via Facebook,
Twitter, Snapchat, et tous les retours que j'ai eus sont plutôt positifs, pour l'instant.
Donc voilà, merci beaucoup !
Et je vous mets le lien dans la description, et ici, quelque part, je ne sais pas encore comment ...
et voilà ! J'espère que ça vous plaira, ça parle de synesthésie, le mélange des sens,
et de cybernétique, et cetera, qui sont des sujets que je trouve passionants !
Voilà ! Je crois que je vous ai à peu près tout dit,
j'ai essayé de faire assez vite parce que je ne voulais pas faire une vidéo hyper longue,
surtout pour finalement ne pas dire grand chose :
que vous me manquez,
ne vous inquiétez pas, il y a des vidéos qui vont revenir en force,
Le Coup de Phil' ne s'arrête pas du tout, il y a un Coup de Phil' qui est prêt,
je peux même vous dire que c'est sur Schopenhauer,
donc ça va être assez intéressant,
et voilà ! Ajoutez-moi sur Snapchat pour suivre ce voyage,
qui va être, j'espère, assez fou,
je suis assez excité en fait, je ne suis jamais parti
aussi loin, aussi longtemps, seul,
donc je suis assez excité !
Et j'espère qu'il n'y a pas un contre-jour un peu relou.
Voilà, et passez ...
et allez voir la vidéo que j'ai faite avec Google,
qui à mon avis sera cool! Donc je vais
repartir dans ce sens-là parce que le soleil ...
c'est mieux que je me le prenne moi!
D'ailleurs, malgré la barbe, et la casquette militaire,
je vous rassure, je ne vais pas du tout en Syrie,
et d'ailleurs, ce que je voulais vous dire c'est : "passez un très bon été",
malgré la morosité ambiante. Je parlais avec des potes hier et
on parlait d'une sorte de métaphore avec la mouche et l'éléphant
vous voyez, genre, un éléphant est hyper balaise, hyper solide et
il y a une petite mouche qui vient, et la mouche va dans l'oreille
et, c'est tout petit mais ça gêne l'éléphant et il bouge, il fait n'importe quoi ...
eh ben ...
soyons l'éléphant mais ne bougons pas trop.
Ayons sa sagesse, la sagesse de l'éléphant.
Voilà. C'est un peu nul. C'est la pire métaphore que j'ai pu sortir, franchement.
Je pense que vous avez compris l'idée.
Je pense que vous avez compris l'idée et que vous allez être induglents avec moi. Voilà.
Je vous fais de gros, gros bisous.
Je vous envoie du love et de la pisse ! Ciao !